JONATHAN ALFERNESS: So anyway.
Real quick, I'm John Alferness.
I work here at Google, and
I've been here for a long time.
But more excitingly is David
Lebovitz, whose here with us
today.
I'm really fortunate
to be able to do this,
because David's actually a
really good friend of mine.
My wife and I have known
David since the early days
where my wife was
a food blogger.
And David certainly, being one
of the most quintessential food
bloggers out there, is somebody
that we got to know early on.
David, for those of
you who don't know,
is just quite an
illuminary in this field.
David worked at Chez
Panisse as the pastry chef
for about 13 years.
He pivoted then
in the late '90s,
I think roughly 1999, where
he started writing more,
starting with blogs.
And if you, I mean
I know for us,
probably 1999 felt like
blogs were in full swing.
But David was really one of the
first food bloggers out there,
and remains one of the most
influential food bloggers
that we continue to see.
Flood bloggers.
David's written, I don't
know how many books.
Probably more than
a half dozen or so.
It's somewhere in
the back pamphlet
of this book, of which I've
used more than a couple
to actually bang out
some great recipes.
His ice cream book, if you
haven't bought it and tried it,
kicks ass.
It's really, really awesome.
Anyway, David's now been living
in Paris for the last 10 years
or so.
He does tours of Paris,
he's introduced us
to our favorite chocolates
here in all the world,
and showed us your wonderful
shop, which unfortunately
had a big fire recently.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Explosion.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Explosion, and then fire.
But she's OK, Denise is OK.
Anyway, David is
here with us today
to answer a few of my questions.
But then more importantly,
answer all of your questions,
probably ask you guys some
questions too about Google
and what we can do for David.
But really, this is just
a huge pleasure for me
and I think for all of us.
So let's take a quick
second to welcome David.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Well, thanks.
Everybody, I have
friends-- Cindy
over here, who tested
recipes for the books,
works at Google for the book.
But whenever I have
Google [INAUDIBLE]
they go oh, that's
not my category.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
We're really going
to evading questions at Google.
So we'll see how good you
are evading questions.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: As a blogger,
I'm getting better at that.
Actually, I need to get
some tips on that too.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: So let's
do the history little bit.
I mean, Chez Panisse,
if you ask me,
is one of, if not the most
quintessential California
restaurants.
I think it really
changed the pace
of how Californians
think about food.
And it just kind of keeps going.
Anybody who's eaten there
over a long period of time
knows the consistency that's
there, and the qualities there.
What was it like working as a
pastry chef at Chez Panisse?
I know you have all kinds
of great anecdotes to share.
Maybe you could
just share a couple.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Well, I
started there, actually it
was right when California
cuisine was just taking off.
And I was actually working
upstairs in the cafe.
And nobody knew at the
time what radicchio
was, what goat cheese was.
And people were coming
in and saying like oh,
is it like tofu?
I was like no, it's goat cheese.
And they're like,
what's goat cheese?
And people didn't know.
And it's kind of funny
how it's evolved.
People used to ask us how we got
the oranges red, because they
were blood oranges.
And it was kind of funny,
and it just kind of took off.
And now radicchio
you take a flight,
or you go to
Disneyland, and they
have radicchio on the salad.
And I just had lunch here,
if Chez Panisse didn't exist,
you guys would probably all be
eating Egg McMuffin sandwiches
rather than all
the beautiful food.
So I give Chez Panisse
a lot of credit,
but it was a very
exciting time in America.
Also coincidentally,
with the rise of Google
and technology, people being
much more aware of what they're
eating, what they're doing,
what they're thinking,
what they're sharing.
And that was also the
birth of food blogs.
When we all, I
started in 1999 when
the word "blog"
didn't even exist.
And people thought I was crazy.
My friends who wrote
books thought I was crazy.
But getting back to the original
question of Chez Panisse,
it's actually been
really interesting
seeing how the Bay
Area once again,
has been so innovative
in promoting food,
promoting technology.
But we sort of tend to make
it really useful and relevant.
So instead of just being this
movement and for the sake
of having a food
movement, it was like no.
This is about feeding people.
This is about having farms.
I mean you think the idea of
having a farm outside of New
York City. is so crazy.
But now it exists, and you
have this farmer's market
with all local produce.
And you go to Safeway and
they have local Straus Milk
and stuff.
And that's all really
pretty radical still.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Yeah.
And recent.
It works here in the Bay Area.
We all kind of embrace it, but--
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Who'd
have thought it?
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: --it's
amazing how much it's spread,
right?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: I
never would've thought
that I'd have kale in my teeth.
I'm like-- we used to eat
iceberg lettuce salad.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Just to
riff off that for a second,
do you think California
and the Bay Area
continues to be one
of the main places
where food is sort of
innovated from like the quality
of ingredients, and
freshness, and organic,
and everything else?
What do you see as you, I mean,
you get around the world a lot.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Right.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Do we have competition
that we should be worried about?
DAVID LEBOVITZ:
I don't think so.
I think actually San
Francisco and the Bay Area's
actually very conservative
in terms of food.
People don't like trends here.
I'm not going to
mention any names,
but there's been a lot of
molecular gastronomy stuff.
And the people have
come through and they've
sold out audiences in
theaters, and so forth.
But nobody, if they had
opened restaurants here,
nobody would have liked them.
Because people really appreciate
very simple, basic food.
Going through the
cafeteria here,
everybody's eating
grilled asparagus.
It's not fancy,
there's no foam on it,
there's no, there's not turkey
and clam ice cream on the side.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: No
stir fried lamb brains,
or anything like that.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: It's a
very conservative food
community here,
but in a good way.
And I think it's really,
like you go to Zuni,
and you get a really good
hamburger or roast chicken.
And you're making this face,
people think about that--
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Sorry, I love Zuni.
But you know that.
That's where we go.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Yeah, you
think about that food,
and you just go wow,
it's really good.
And it doesn't need to be fancy.
Just let the ingredients
speak for itself.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: It's one of
the reasons I love living here.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: But quality
always speaks for itself.
There's a lot of stuff out
there as everybody knows;
you work for search
engine company.
The good stuff rises to the top.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Well,
that's why Alice can get away
with serving a bowl of fruit as
her main dessert course, right?
Some of the best fruit
that you'll ever eat,
but completely undressed,
completely naked.
What was it that,
what was your pivot?
What made you say well,
I'm an amazing pastry chef
and I love doing
this, but damn it.
I want to write full time, and
I want to make this my career?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: I turned 40.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Ah, I see.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Restaurant
work is really hard.
And during that whole
California cuisine movement,
I guess it was the '80s, '90s.
Everybody wanted to be a chef.
And I still hear
that from people.
When I worked in the kitchen
at Chez Panisse's, people
who are lawyers who used to
come in the kitchen and go,
I would love to do this.
And you're like,
do you really want
to do this for minimum wage?
And do you really want
to peel apples all day?
Yeah.
Maybe have dinner parties and
subscribe to Martha Stewart,
build a nice kitchen, and
we all live hand to mouth.
So there was a lot of people
who are getting into cooking,
myself included at the time,
we worked really, really hard.
Somebody recently
asked me on Twitter,
how do I get to do what you do?
I was like, you stand
at the back of a kitchen
and you roll dough for 30 years.
But when I hit 40
I was like, what
am I going to do with
the rest of my life?
I couldn't stand up all day.
I was just tired.
I was really, I'd done the
same thing over and over.
And one thing, one
equality Americans
have that I've learned
from living in Europe,
is we're really good at
reinventing ourselves.
We're very good
at saying you know
what, I'm tired of
being an architect.
I want to open a cupcake shop,
or let's start a search engine,
I'm going to write a book.
We do that, and we just
say I'm going to do it.
And if it doesn't work, it's OK.
But we're not
afraid to try stuff.
So I just thought you know what?
It's time to turn the Etch a
Sketch over, give it a shake,
and start again.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Is that what,
was it sort of the break
in switching to writing
and your pseudo midlife crisis
that sent you to Paris as well,
or was it-- I mean, I know
you've always loved Paris.
And I'm not surprised
that you live there now.
What brought you to Paris then?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: I
don't really know.
I didn't have
anything to do here.
I'd lived in San Francisco
for 20 something years.
I was like, you know what?
I want to go somewhere else.
And I thought, well Paris--
I was never a francophile.
I wasn't like oh my God, my
dream is to live in Paris.
Audrey Hepburn.
I just wanted to go, I thought
it'd be an interesting place.
And it was.
It's a really good
place to write,
because nobody bothers you.
People, you can stay in your
apartment for weeks and months,
and nobody thinks that's weird.
Cindy's laughing
because she lived there.
And it's true.
You could sit in
a cafe by yourself
and you're not distracted.
And also for me, I
developed as a writer there.
Because everything
I do there, if I
go out and get a loaf of
bread, if I open my front door,
there's material.
There's a story.
Everything I do, buying
shoelaces, getting
yelled at, buying
cheese, whatever.
Coming up with a recipe.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: You've
shared a lot of those stories--
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Too much.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
--with me and my wife.
I don't know that they're
all appropriate for a work
audience, but are there
a couple anecdotes
that you can share
just to sort of comment
on the quirkiness
of living in Paris?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Well,
it was interesting.
I recently went
out to where they
harvest the salt off
the Atlantic coast.
And if you look
at a map of France
from the air, Google Earth, you
can see all these salt marshes
that have been around
since Roman times.
And the people hand harvest
this salt, and it's amazing.
You go to a store here
and you buy, and it's $12.
And we went there.
We spent a weekend
because I wanted
to see the salt being harvested.
And we're sitting in this
restaurant right on the coast.
Beautiful salt marshes,
beautiful piles of salt
that they'd all faked.
And on the table
is industrial salt.
The worst salt in the world.
And I said to the waitress
I said, it's kind of funny.
It's right out, you have it.
And they're like, oh.
They just didn't
even notice that,
because it didn't
even occur to them.
So that kind of stuff, being
an outsider is actually funny.
Because my partner's French,
and he's pretty funny.
Have you met Roman?
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: I've
heard a lot about Roman.
I don't think
we've ever met, no.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: And so
I get motivated by him.
He thinks I'm funny
too, most of the time.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: That's
good, because you are.
The other one that
I'll throw out there,
I don't know if David remembers.
He'll remember the place that
we were eating at in Paris.
But we get to, what was the
name of the restaurant, again?
DAVID LEBOVITZ:
The black plates.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: We're going
to the ketchup on lobster.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Yeah.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: So you're
going through an exquisite meal
in Paris, and David
and I will have
rack brains for the
name of the place.
But it was one of the
places on the list
that my wife knew that
she wanted to go to.
And of course, you
meet up with David
and you magically get
into these places.
And we're working
through the meal.
Really elegant, fancy, high end,
three star sort of French food.
And we get to the
lobster course.
And everybody's excited
about the lobster course
because the three
of us love lobster.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Lobster's
very expensive in France.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
That's right.
And it can be really good.
I mean, the French
know how to cook
lobster, which is
not overcook it.
But then that lobster
was drenched in a,
and how would we
say it in French?
What was the name of the sauce?
I it was straight up, it
read as, "cat soup sauce."
And I'm like, what
the hell is this?
And it was just
straight ketchup.
And the waiter comes
out, and is really,
really proud of the sauce
that they put on this lobster.
Because it was ketchup
that was made specially
by this friend of his,
et cetera, et cetera.
And the three of us are
eating it trying to enjoy it.
But again from an outsider
perspective just going, well
shit.
They just put ketchup
on my lobster.
I don't know, just I
can imagine all kinds
of fascinating
stories like that.
Let's pivot a little
bit to the book.
I want to make sure
we give folks a chance
to ask questions, as well.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Sure.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
This is, you've
written a whole bunch of books.
You've largely focused more
specifically on cookbooks.
Now, you're taking
a pivot to more
of what I would kind of deem
a memoir cross cookbook.
What was it the sort of
motivated you to do that?
Why the bigger journey, the
more work, the, I don't know.
DAVID LEBOVITZ:
More work is the--
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Yeah, you just
wanted to do the more work?
DAVID LEBOVITZ:
Do the harder way.
Yeah, it's the
Chez Panisse thing.
I always find the
harder way to do it.
I'd written a memoir,
when I moved to Paris,
my blog kind of took off.
And a lot of people
were saying well,
you should write a
book about your story.
So I wrote a book at the time,
which was very well received.
And it was kind of funny,
and very young and fresh.
And we change.
People look at my old recipes,
I had a chance to revise a book.
And I was like oh, I don't make
the brownies like that anymore.
I do this now.
And that changed, so that
changed, and that changed.
My life has changed a lot.
So I'd proposed a
book to my publisher,
who I love, Ten Speed Press.
Just a book about France,
another book about stories.
And the publisher,
Aaron, who's great,
said it needs to have recipes.
I was like [CRYING].
And I'd spent eight months
working on the proposal, which
is what you normally
do when writing a book.
And he said well, we
need to have recipes.
And to make a long story
short, I realized he was right.
Because as a cook, my
story is through recipes.
My story's through cooking.
I cook all day, and
that's who I am.
I'm a cook.
I've been a cook since
I was 16 professionally.
Well, I was a dishwasher in a
restaurant-- dishwasher bonanza
sirloin pit, and
then the guys who
tended the meat in the naugahyde
aprons used to terrorize me
with the flaming
stakes and stuff.
We're going to throw
you on the fire.
And now I'm like,
where are they now?
I'm in Google.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Come, join me.
Last question that
I'll ask, and then we
should turn it over to
friends in the audience.
I've heard that you
had an opportunity
to redo your kitchen.
I know your kitchen for
your already small Parisian
apartment was not very large.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Right.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
I don't know.
Talk to us a little bit
about the kitchen remodel.
What you did, what
you're happy about.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: OK,
well the short answer
is when I started the remodeling
project, a friend of mine
in Paris said, promise
me you won't write
a book about
remodeling in France.
I said, OK.
And then that all the stuff
happened, and it was pretty,
it was very difficult.
I was working on the
book at the time,
and actually if anyone here has
ever bought a house in America,
it takes 30 days.
And France takes about
a year, just to close.
It's really stressful, and
it's all very difficult.
And then it needed
to be remodeled.
And I thought, I've
done remodeling here.
I'm like well, let's
just put this here,
and this here, I want
a nice big kitchen.
And to condense
the story, people
were walking by
like on the street.
They were looking
and they were like,
are you building
a restaurant here?
I'm like oh, that's the kitchen.
They're like--
because I have a big,
I was like I want a
big area to cook in.
Traditionally actually,
French people always
had the kitchen apart
from their apartments.
You never wanted, I mean
going back in history,
the maid always made the food.
Like you didn't, it's
very class orient--
you didn't want to be
around the smell of food.
So they have this,
the new concept is,
they call it cuisine American,
or an American kitchen.
Which is open with a big counter
and everybody likes that,
and you see the
stools and stuff.
But it was very challenging.
A lot of stuff,
you're tech people.
I said, I want USB ports.
We're doing the electricity.
So I came home one
day, and there's
these cords hanging
out of the wall.
It was like the wrong way.
So I was like-- I was like, no.
I need to plug my stuff into
the wall, not my apartment
into my computer.
So we had a two week
argument about that.
And there's a story in the book
about how the new contractor
saved my life,
because I found out
there was CO2 gas being
pumped into my apartment.
And I was wondering why
was sleeping so well.
I was like, I've been
sleeping really well lately.
12, 24 hours.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Well, that's
the trick to sleeping well.
Maybe I just need--
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Well, I
don't recommend it, but--
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: So why don't
we open up to everybody else?
My guess is lots of good
questions for David.
There's a mike floating around.
Who has some good questions?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Or even
regular [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: OK.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: If you have any
questions about the recipe--
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: And if
you don't have questions,
David's going to ask
how to get higher
in the search results ranking,
how to drop his AdWords cost,
why the street view
picture of his home--
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Shows
the bathroom, shower.
Everyone's always like,
that's not my department.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: M-hm.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I'm a big fan.
Thank you for all the
wonderful recipes on your blog,
and beautiful photos on
your Instagram, and Google+,
and everything.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Oh,
I'm a fan of Google.
[INAUDIBLE] feedback.
AUDIENCE: Really appreciate it.
And you really made
my last trip to Paris
with all the recommendations
and things on your blog.
If you were moving
back to San Francisco,
what are some things
you would really
take from your Paris experience
that would maybe transform
the way you would
live here again?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: The way I shop.
I'm used to, I mean I walk
everywhere, and I shop.
I go to the bakery everyday,
and I go to the cheese shop,
and I have people at the market.
And here, it's so
easy to buy stuff.
You go to the supermarket,
you drive up to a place,
and you just buy everything.
And I would still really
try to hold on to that,
like getting my milk from
one place and cheese.
And even though it
drives you crazy
if you're trying to do a
cookbook, because you know.
It's like, I need an orange.
And the store's
closed until Monday,
and you have to wait until
Tuesday because they don't
have anyone to stock the store.
And Cindy's laughing because
you remember this stuff.
It's like OK.
So just going more small scale.
And actually, eating everything.
When I left the
restaurant business,
I was a little chunky.
And I was always a thin person,
and I made a conscious effort
to lose a lot of weight.
And I was trying
to eat egg whites,
and not eat so much fat.
In France, I eat everything.
And I've kind of lost weight
until this trip right now.
And I've just been eating
ribs and stuff, so.
I probably wouldn't
eat all this stuff
that I used to eat in
America like tacos,
or burritos, and stuff.
Does that makes sense?
No lobster with ketchup.
AUDIENCE: So it's a
two part question.
As a technologist
and a home cook,
I always have this love hate
relationship with sort of tech,
right?
How much is going to be
useful in the kitchen?
Most the time it's
useless to me,
but-- so it's two part question.
One is, what other kinds, if you
have any tech in your kitchen,
what is it?
And then the other
is if you don't, what
would be great to have
that maybe doesn't exist?
DAVID LEBOVITZ:
You know, I don't.
Years before the iPad came
out, I did a story on my site
about ecookbooks.
Because there were some
devices that had recipes.
I'm like, you know,
is this going to work?
Are people going to want to
look at a tablet and cook?
It even if you could
have Julia Child with you
on this thing saying cut
up the chicken this way.
And when I write recipes,
I write them all longhand.
And even downstairs,
the test kitchen woman,
she's still writing longhand.
So I don't really have
any tech in my kitchen.
I don't use a computer
when I'm typing recipes.
That's in another room.
What I would like is,
and I know this exists,
but I'm just too crazy to do it.
Is a voice activated
tool so I could
say, chop one onion, so I didn't
have to stop and write it down.
Or something that
would record what I do,
and condense it so that I
could just have it right
there without having
to go through all
this recordings of stuff.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
I can, is that sort
of what you had in mind?
Or would you broaden your
question as well to like,
do you have a KitchenAid
mixer in your kitchen--
AUDIENCE: No, it actually
wasn't about the gadgets.
Well, there's a
school of thought
that says you only need a
chef's knife and a paring knife,
right?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
more on that school.
But you could broaden it to
OK, when you're not cooking,
and you go online
to look and see
what other people are doing.
Maybe you're looking for a
recipe or online services--
although just to your
point about dictation,
we definitely have that.
But it's not structured
for that use case.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Yeah, you
see these refrigerators
that tell you when
you need milk.
It's like, I don't need that.
I can open the door.
But I need a
computer to write on,
I need a computer to
go search for a recipe,
or search for a technique.
So a lot of this innovation in
the kitchen this kind of silly.
And this whole idea of a
chef's knife, a paring knife,
and a pan is really great.
I've gone to people's
houses, I was actually
somewhere the other day.
And they had turkey deep fryer.
It was a machine just
for deep frying turkey.
And--
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: That's
highly useful, right?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: It's highly
useful one day of the year.
It's people who have these very
big kitchens, and so forth.
And I lived in a really, I
had a really nice kitchen
here in San Francisco.
And then I moved to a
very small place in Paris.
I didn't have a
mixer for a year,
and I just had a couple pans.
And I wrote two books there.
And it was good,
because I could write
to people who have
small kitchens.
Light up your wok
burner, and heat up
six gallons of rice
bran oil, and then
fry the quail hearts until, and
you're just-- all those kind
of books kind of freak me out.
Because I love when people
come to me and they go,
I made your recipe
for madelines.
They were great.
I made your vanilla ice
cream, it was great.
And that's what it's all about.
And I think in spite of
how great technology is,
it's just not, cooking
is a visceral experience.
That's why books, I
wrote this book because,
if you need a recipe
for chocolate cake,
you can go online and find one.
I wrote this book
because I wanted people
to read about my life,
read about the recipes,
and pick it up, and
touch it, and feel it.
I chose the photographer,
because he's very,
he's good at getting the sort
of the textures of vegetables,
and meat, and Paris.
Paris is not necessarily
a beautiful place.
It is, but there's a
lot of funkiness to it,
like the ethnic neighborhoods.
I live near Belleville, which
is an Asian neighborhood.
And people are like,
there's Asians in Paris?
I'm like yeah, there's
a huge neighborhood.
There's Indian neighborhoods.
And I thought those short of
showed the diversity of Paris,
and I wanted to show
that in the book.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Other
questions from folks now,
a few more hands going up.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So two things.
One is I wanted to
admit, I've never
made a single one
of your recipes.
But that's not because I
don't like your recipies.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: The
books are for sale.
AUDIENCE: No, no, no, no, no.
It's because I have to
deal with my family,
with over a dozen
different food allergies.
Milk allergy, milk,
wheat, dairy, eggs.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: But
you probably have
recipes that you make
over and over again.
AUDIENCE: Absolutely
DAVID LEBOVITZ: That's great.
Yeah, that's what you do.
AUDIENCE: And I actually
love you for your stories.
So I'm really excited
about your new book,
and I read your blog religiously
because of the stories.
And what I imagine your
recipes would taste like.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: OK.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: OK.
AUDIENCE: The other thing
is that I had a question
for you is, how do you
balance that with Google, you
can find like you said,
chocolate ginger cake
recipe, right?
Which is one of those I
imagine, yours is amazing.
But you can search for a
million of those recipes.
So how do you differentiate
yours with all the other ones?
How do you balance making
it special enough, but not
so esoteric that
normal people will,
oh, that's way too many steps.
That's way too many ingredients,
that's way too weird.
So how do you balance that?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Well
the way I've actually,
and this probably
sounds terrible,
and you can turn the
cameras off when I say this,
but I'm seeing a stratification
now on the internet.
There's so much content.
If you want that ginger
cake, you type ginger cake.
But whose recipe is it?
Who's written this recipe?
If you go on a site
like Epicurious,
they have a test kitchen.
And the recipe works,
there's someone behind it.
If people go to my
site, I test the recipe.
I test them two or three times.
For the book, at least
three times, if not more.
And then Cindy gets the
recipe and goes over them.
I vet the stuff.
People want curated,
vetted content.
There's so much stuff out
there that's not good.
I want my name to be, I've
become a trusted name.
I didn't do it intentionally,
but I have that chops.
Because I'm a cookbook
writer, as well.
So you can turn the
camera back on again now.
But I actually try to cook
for a global audience.
A third of my readers on my
site are from outside the US.
So I'm very conscious of
if I call for a recipe,
I write in grams,
if I use molasses,
people are going to
say, what's molasses?
And I'm very conscious of that.
And that sort of endeared
me to a larger audience.
Americans, we tend to be
enclosed in our country.
And even though
Google's international,
the internet makes us, we still
work within our own parameters.
And I'm always constantly
trying to enforce this idea,
suggest this idea,
that we need to think
about the rest of the world.
How people in England cook,
what they use, and so forth.
Does that answer
the second question?
AUDIENCE: Sort of.
Just, there are lots
of recipes where
they use very hard
to find ingredients.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: I actually--
AUDIENCE: Especially
living in France, you know?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: I actually
don't use ingredients
that people can't get anywhere.
I search a lot on the line.
I always make sure that
anything in the book is,
and actually, I try to
make sure everything's
available in the community.
There's nothing more
annoying than making a recipe
and go, oh, I have to
mail away for the spice.
I do ask Cindy, I've written
butchers or called butchers,
or emailed, I guess, in Texas.
I'm like when you get a
ham hock, is it smoked?
Can you get on
unsmoked hem hocks?
So they're like, yes.
But things like
sausages, I really want,
and I give suggestions.
For example, I have
a cassoulet recipe.
And everybody's
like cassoulet has
to be made with these beans.
And they're these
haricot tarbais beans.
And in America, they're
probably $30, $35 a pound.
And it's hard to do a
recipe to tell somebody, buy
two pounds of these beans.
Because it's annoying,
and it's a peasant dishes.
It's not, the esprit
or the soul of the dish
is to something that
anybody can make with,
that's what French cuisine is.
It's regional food
too, what's available.
So I try to encourage people
to use what's available.
And there's only one
ingredient in the book which
is salt cod, which
I love a lot, which
you might have to send away for.
But other than that,
everything else is,
I really strive to make
stuff that people can make.
I've seen a lot of
chef's books with the 1/4
cup of squab stock, and
this-- I'm like, OK.
They're just showing off.
Or that's how they
cook in a restaurant,
but that's not how
people cook, I think.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: It's OK.
Here in the Bay Area, salt
cod is kind of the same thing
as on endive these days.
So like--
DAVID LEBOVITZ: They couldn't
get it at Camino yesterday.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Really?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Yeah.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Oh, strange.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
See it everywhere.
What other questions?
AUDIENCE: So, I've been
to Paris several times,
but my wife's never been.
She's fluent in French.
Barring an invitation to
your place, where would
you suggest, what do you suggest
we would taste, or a place we
would eat, or I think
we'll have a kitchen.
What should we make
ourselves to understand Paris
or to be surprised by Paris?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: I
think a couple things.
If you're going to rent an
apartment, which is great,
eat bread and cheese.
The bread and cheese
are outstanding.
And you get really good bread
and cheese in the Bay Area,
but it's not the same.
Just eat a lot of cheese,
because it's spectacular.
And for restaurants,
it's getting harder
to find a traditional
restaurant.
Because people don't eat
that way anymore in Paris.
We ate at this bistro.
We had some deer stew and for
two days were like, oh my god.
I'm still digesting it.
But there's a lot
of young talent.
Like Septime, 6 Paul Bert, where
they're doing fresh ingredients
like small peas, flowers.
But not silly, but very
beautiful things, like whoa.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: If you
want, we can go play pool.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Yeah,
we're doing it after.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Yeah, OK.
[INAUDIBLE] ball pit?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Six Paul
Bert, Septime, and wine bars.
A lot of Americans are a little
timid to go into a wine bar.
But that's where all
the young people, those
are the bistros of today.
That's where the
young people hang out,
people go for casual meal.
You can get charcuterie cheese,
a glass of wine, or two,
or three.
That's fun.
You don't have to
have a reservation.
The people are nice,
the young generation
is much more accommodating.
And they're happy to
see you, and so forth.
AUDIENCE: Thanks very much.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: What
other questions do folks have?
AUDIENCE: Right here.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: I
have a question.
What is the cue ball doing?
Oh, Cindy, you're back.
CINDY: I'm back Is this on?
I was wondering
if you could talk
about any particularly
contentious topics
on your blog, or topics
that are eternally popular.
Just sort of things that always
strike a chord with people.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Yeah, I'm like
blogger chef, pastry chef,
slash referee.
So sometimes I have
a couple things.
Well, whenever I go
anywhere, everyone's
always like oh, you should
have gone to some restaurant.
Just like the should'ves the
should'ves, you should'ves.
And that's always, like
why didn't you go here?
I'm like well, because
I'm here for a day.
So that's always a
point of contention.
People, they think I should
go to all these places and I
can't.
The authenticity police.
I've recently had a
few run ins with them,
and they've tried to bust me.
And that's a really big thing.
There's a lot of people online.
Everybody's an
expert, and they all
want to point out that
they know more than you do.
Which is often true.
But once again, like
I was talking about.
Thai food, like food changes.
Cassoulet is not,
somebody wrote to me
recently one of these things.
They said well, I was
looking at your book.
And I'm not going to buy it.
Because it's a book
on French food,
but there are some
non-French recipes in there.
There's tarjine.
And French people eat tarjine.
It's like Americans
eat hamburgers.
Hamburgers are not
American, they're German.
Cassoulet is beans
from the new world.
Beans are not native to France.
So people, we're
talking a little bit
about different cultures.
Not everything's
available everywhere.
We're very fortunate in America.
If you need Parmesan, if you
need pecarino, you can get it.
But if you can't get
the bouillabaise fish,
does that mean you
can't make bouillabaise?
No.
Because bouillabaise
is a peasant dish
using fish from the region.
So you use what's available.
You don't use what they use in
Marseille, because it's silly.
You live in San Francisco.
So the authenticity police,
I'm flipping over the word,
you can edit that out.
That's been sort of a
point of contention.
And I address that
now in blog posts.
And I say, this is an
authentic, but I live in Paris.
And we don't get this,
we don't get tomatillo,
so this is what I use.
And that's the best you can do.
And get your-- I tell people
if they don't like it,
they can start their
own blog and write
about how I'm doing
everything wrong.
I won't link to it, but--
and you guys don't either.
I have friends at Google,
and they'll cut you--
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Lower.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Yeah.
Move the algorithm.
AUDIENCE: I want
to thank you again
for your blog and your books.
I love them all.
You mentioned you moved
to Paris to learn.
I'm curious what
other countries,
or maybe even
regions of France you
would want to spend
more time in, and learn
more about their style
of cooking, and eating,
and so forth.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: I love the Jura.
People think France, they
think Paris, Provence.
Because Provence is very
accessible, especially
for Californians.
Because the food
is great, it's all
vegetables, blah,
blah, blah, garlic.
But the Jura is the mountainous
region where they make cheese.
Comte cheese, [? Mondoora. ?]
There's these wines there
that you don't get outside
of France very often.
They often have a funny
taste, almost sherry like.
A little oxidized.
I've been there a few times.
We went once, and our car rolled
off a cliff, and it was pretty.
They're like, this
happens all the time.
And I remember my friend and I,
our car's rolling off a cliff.
And we're looking at each other
like, are we going to die?
And we're talking about
it, and he's French.
But it's a really
beautiful part of France.
I'd like to learn more
about Alsauce too.
They have a really, they
have wonderful wines.
And people think
oh, Riesling, sweet.
It's like no, it's not sweet.
It's very good wine.
I don't know anything about it.
So I'd like to go
there and learn more.
And that's how you learn
about stuff in France.
You go there and you
see them make it.
And now I know a lot
about comte cheese.
You say [? compte, ?]
but in French,
you say [? conte. ?]
I don't know why.
But that's how I
learn about stuff.
I go to places.
I've gone to places
where they candy fruit.
I've gone to cheese
caves, and stuff.
And now I know.
I'm like wow, this
is fascinating.
[INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: While
folks are queueing up,
some additional questions.
You want to spend just
a minute or two talking
about Denise Acabo and the
fantastic shop she has.
And then, maybe go into
the story a little bit
about the recent tragedy,
and where she's taking it.
I'll just real
briefly set up that I
think one of David's
specialties has been,
I mean clearly desserts, pastry
chef, et cetera, but also
in chocolate.
And I've learned, although
I know very little,
I've learned most
everything that I
know from talking to David.
David goes really deep.
All the way into, but
are you actually making
your own chocolate?
Are you buying it
from somebody else
to make what you have here?
And he understands things
at the level of people
essentially roasting beans,
and making chocolate.
In fact, you were at
Dandelion Chocolate
just the other day in San
Francisco, weren't you?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: It's funny how
some people say "dan-dee-lion."
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Or what is it--
DAVID LEBOVITZ:
How do you say it?
I say dandelion.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS Oh, I was
saying "dan-dee-lion," I guess.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: It's OK.
It's like tomatoe, tomato.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Yeah, I guess so.
And they're one
of the few places
I think in the Bay Area that
actually makes their own,
makes own chocolate, right?
But Denise Acobo has this
amazing chocolate shop
in Paris.
And it was, I mean, it's
just so stuck in our memories
as one of the places
that my wife and I'd
love to visit when
we were last there.
We brought our kids.
And she's an amazing
woman walking around,
pulling out so the best
treats, chocolates, candies,
that you've ever
had in your life.
You want to just talk a little
bit about how you guys met,
and some of the, like she's got
a hold of special chocolates,
but she had to beg
to get a hold of them
and all this kind of stuff.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: It's the
only 80-year-old woman
who kisses me on the lips.
Like, OK.
Actually, the Dandelion
people are great.
They actually came to Paris,
and I showed them around.
I didn't know them.
And they were like,
we're thinking
of opening a chocolate place.
And I was telling them, the
used to own [? Plaxo, ?] I
think, and they sold it.
And that's what Americans
are really good at,
in reinventing ourselves.
And they did.
I was like well, you know,
it's going to be really hard,
and blah, blah.
And they opened, they
acknowledged me effusively
for influencing them,
which I didn't really do.
They did it.
But it was great.
So they're a very
good example of that.
But Denise Acobo
had a shop in Paris
for maybe 35 years called
A L'Etoile d'Or, which
is "The Golden Star."
Doesn't sound very sexy in
English, so you use the French.
But she was curating
candies and specialty
treats from all over France.
And the store was like
a little antique shop,
and she wore a little pigtail,
like little girl pigtails,
a tie, kilt.
Have you?
You've been in the shop.
Oh, no.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: She's
like quintessential,
like what you would expect for
a little old lady in a candy
shop.
DAVID LEBOVITZ:
But she's lovely.
She loves people, she
loves talking to people,
she loves tourists.
She's like, Americans are
so great, everybody wants,
she loves talking to people.
And there's a
couple of chocolates
that she, she was
the only place that
carried Burnachon
chocolates from Lyon.
Lyon.
And she said, I got down
on my hands and knees
in front of the owner.
And it's like ay, it's
an 80-year old woman.
When I was in her
apartment once upstairs.
And she was like, yeah, Toulouse
Lautrec used to live back here.
And I'm like, wow.
And about two months
ago, her shop,
there was an
explosion underneath.
Somebody was working on the gas
line, and the shop exploded.
And the pharmacy
next door exploded,
and the whole floor collapsed.
And she was in there
with customers.
And luckily, she's OK, but she
that she saw the whole floor
collapse.
As a testament to good building
materials, a lot of the shelves
are marble, so they
protected the chocolate.
But the shop was destroyed
and is destroyed.
And it's very sad,
because she's 80.
And she's really lively,
she's very alert.
And she really misses
people having this store,
it's her whole life.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
But she's not
in the process of rebuilding it?
DAVID LEBOVITZ:
Well, I had talks
with her and her
daughter, and they've
thought about ecommerce.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Ecommerce?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Ecommerce.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Here,
in the states, maybe?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: (FRENCH
ACCENT) Ecommerce.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
(FRENCH ACCENT) Ecommerce.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: It sounds
effective, I'm sorry.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: I like it.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: I'll be one
of those annoying people that
comes back from Europe
with a British accent.
But she wanted to, I'm
like, you're in France,
and nobody's going to,
people want to come here.
And you went in the shop,
and every single person
I sent in that shop
was like, that was
our favorite shop in Paris.
And that was actually one
of the reasons I started.
I really worked on
the blog actually,
it started before
I moved to Paris.
But it was all these shops
that nobody had heard about.
They were mentioned
very briefly,
but the magazines
were like, we want
to talk about Lauderee,
and [INAUDIBLE].
I'm like, this shop is amazing.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Yeah.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: It's up at
Montemartre, near Moulin Rouge.
And we had lunch.
She's a fixture in
the neighborhood.
You go up there and
everybody you walk by.
And people come out
of their shops to say,
I'm sorry what
happened to your store.
So I said, let's do
some pop up stores.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Oh,
Kickstarter campaign,
pop up stores, or
someone like that?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Yeah.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: What
other questions do folks have?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: And I want to
do a Google Glass tour of Paris.
That's my question for you guys.
It'd be fun to do a video in
Paris wearing the glasses.
So just putting that out there.
You can have the glasses
back when I'm done.
AUDIENCE: Just kind
of a hopeful question.
You mentioned how bread here
is good, but not the same.
And I agree.
Any tips on where we could
get a close approximation
of the bread and
amazing croissants
that we in Paris if you've
seen anything similar here?
And if I can ask a follow-up
question to something someone
raised earlier.
I've really been impressed
with the community
you've built, like in your blog.
And I'm sure it's
a tough balance
between the free
content you offer,
and the services
and books that you
sell, anything you
can share about.
And I'm sure moderating
your comments,
so that it's a positive
community on your blog.
And that's been really amazing.
So anything you've kind of
learned that you'd share
would be really interesting.
DAVID LEBOVITZ:
These two questions
I always forget them
one after the other.
You guys have really
good questions.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
[INAUDIBLE] more important.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: OK,
well I can do both,
but you might have to remind me.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
-baguettes and croissants.
DAVID LEBOVITZ:
The baguettes, I've
actually been going
to B. Patisserie.
And in California,
she's is amazing.
The granola is amazing.
She does really, Evelyn, people
are nodding in the audience.
She's doing a really good job.
She's working with
a French bread
guy who actually
lives in the Bay Area.
He's lived here a long time.
But he's an expert on flour.
So she's making these pastries,
and they're beautiful.
They're as good or
better than France.
Josey Bread, Josey Baker bread
at The Mill is fantastic.
He's just a really cool guy.
I visit him every morning
because he makes me happy.
The fact of building a food
community, I was fortunate.
Because when I started my blog,
there was like six bloggers.
And we all kind of
knew each other.
And then we kind of built
this sort of nucleus.
And we still keep in touch,
we still have the same values.
Always be honest, write
from the heart, which
sounds a little touchy feely.
But really express yourself.
Be honest and open.
I also don't let
people push me around.
I have an exit only policy
where I am the boss,
and I don't let people dictate
what I do at all on my site.
I keep it, I moderate it,
not in terms of comments
necessarily, but in
terms of the tone.
When I write about, people
don't like what I write about,
I encourage them
not to read my blog.
And it's fine, I don't care.
They can, the home page
is fixed on my site.
They should contact
their browser,
but I really make an effort
also to be fair on my site.
If you read my older
posts, I'm a lot more maybe
critical of France.
And as the longer
I live there, I
realize that's why they
are the way they are.
And I've chosen to live there.
And I have to learn why, and
I've learned why they are,
why they go on strike.
I don't understand right now
the pilots are going on strike
because they want to take away
their right to go on strike.
So it does actually makes sense.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Oh,
that works actually.
Yeah.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Wra
my head around it.
So I've really tried
to be fair, as well.
And I make fun of myself a
lot, because I'm an idiot.
I go to Paris, and
I make mistakes.
We all make mistakes.
And people come to
France and they're like,
oh it's OK if I take pictures?
I don't want to
look like a tourist.
I'm like, if they
came to San Francisco,
they be at a fisherman's wharf
eating soup out of bread.
So don't worry about it.
Be yourself, be funny.
It's OK to be a tourist,
it's OK to make mistakes.
And I make fun of that,
and I write about that.
If you guys come, we're not
getting the soup and the brand.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: N0?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: In Paris, no.
No baguettes.
Soup [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Well,
you looked at me pretty funny
when I wanted, it's cheeky,
but one of my favorites
is a really good bowl
of French onion soup.
And I was asking David
like, where the hell
can I get this in Paris?
And he was like,
you're in Paris.
You're not going to get
good French onion soup.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Well, it's
just not something people eat.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
That's right.
DAVID LEBOVITZ:
That's the thing you
used to eat at 3:00 in the
morning when the bar's closed,
and it's just that era's over.
And you can get it,
but it's not the same.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: He's right.
Because we went to, I
forget where we showed up.
And I ordered the French
onion soup, and it was crap.
And he's, see?
I told you so.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Yeah.
Well, it's like
going to the Haight,
and experiencing the
free love movement.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Yeah, exactly.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: There's
some relics of it,
but it's kind of [GRIMACES.]
You're going to take a shower,
and maybe go to the
doctor afterwards.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Literal relics.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Yeah.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: We have time
for a couple more questions,
I think.
OK.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Oh, hi.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
So after grad school, I
had a French roommate.
And she introduced me
to such great cuisine.
Oh my god, the cheese.
But then I became
lactose intolerant.
So it's uncomfortable
for everyone involved.
How do you still
enjoy French cooking,
but not be able to handle cream?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: I'm
lactose intolerant.
I actually, when I was
younger-- I've never told them,
I'm telling this on camera.
But they didn't know
what was wrong with me.
I was doubled over in pain.
I was like 12.
And then I went to college, and
I took food science classes.
I'm like, lactose
intolerant-- oh, that's me.
And I stopped drinking
milk by the glass.
And I mean, I'm not an expert.
But most lactose
intolerants can tolerate
a certain amount of dairy.
I can eat ice
cream, and so forth.
Hard mountain cheeses,
there's very little,
if any lactose in them.
It's all been, I don't
quite know the process.
But old cheeses, crumbly
cheeses, don't have lactose.
Goat milk, yogurt.
I love goat milk, I
love sheep's milk.
Those, the lactose
is broken down.
I actually don't
like cream sauces.
I don't like stuff
that's swimming in cream.
I like butter a lot.
Butter in France is
cultured, so I can eat that.
So move to France.
People think I'm crazy for
not liking cream sauce,
but I don't know.
I find that cream, stuff
that's really rich,
you don't taste the food.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Yeah.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: There's
not a lot of stuff
with cream in my book.
I like chocolate,
I like spice, I'd
rather use those
ingredients than cream.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: What's your
favorite thing to cook at home?
Both for a meal when you and
Roman are hungry, but then also
for a treat?
What's your favorite
dessert to cook, as well?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: I
make a lot of sorbet,
because I'm a Californian.
I go to the market,
and I see fruit.
And I'm just
obsessed with fruit.
I'm really crazy about fruit.
And I see stuff, and I
can't help but buying it,
and I buy too much of
it, and I make sorbet.
And I always make fruit with it.
I love cookies, I'm
always making cookies.
I make a lot of biscotti.
I would do sable,
the French cookies,
the thin ones with the butter.
With lime zest, or something.
So I make a lot of those
kind of things for dessert.
The problem is if I make a cake
or something, I work at home.
I'm always slicing pieces off.
And I'll just scrape
some of the icing.
Oh I can't eat, that
piece doesn't have icing,
let me cut it.
I have neighbors,
and they're always
getting cakes with
two slices out.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
This one's left.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Yeah.
Like, thanks, I think.
AUDIENCE: What's next?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: What's next?
Well, it's funny.
Because people ask that a lot.
And often, people say having
a book is like having a baby.
And I've never had a baby,
so I'm just imagining it.
But once you've had a
baby, you don't really
want to be in that situation
again for at least nine months.
So I'm taking nine months off.
It's actually really great
going around and just talking
to people.
Because I spent so much, I
put a lot into this book.
And people say
that all the time,
I'm like-- this was pretty,
it's a lot of me in the book.
It took two years
rather than one.
So I'm actually enjoying
sort of talking about it,
and reflecting on it, and
thinking about what I did.
And I have an idea for
another book about France.
It's a whole different
subject for me.
I'm actually one of
those people that if I
want to write about it, you
want to be an expert on it.
So I'm trying to learn
about this subject,
but it's proving challenging.
That's all I'll say.
But it involves whisky.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Oh.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Yeah.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Fun, I like that.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: So I'm trying
to drink as much as I can.
When's the meeting this
afternoon with the--
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: I
don't know, we should go.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: There's
a cocktail meeting.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Yeah, yeah.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: I have
a driver, it's great.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: I think
we're just about out of time.
Any other questions
from the audience?
If not, I'll wrap up
with the last question.
Where are we e for
dinner tonight?
DAVID LEBOVITZ:
Where are we eating?
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Well,
I know we're not eating.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Oh, I wish.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS:
Well, we still could.
But where are you for dinner?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: I'm actually
going to Left Bank in Larkspur.
They're doing a dinner for me.
Last night they did a
dinner at Camino in Oakland.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Yeah.
DAVID LEBOVITZ:
Which is fantastic.
And tonight is
Left Bank, which is
a more classic
French restaurant.
Camino, I've worked with
Russell for many years
at Chez Panisse,
whose the chef owner.
And I just let
him do what I ask.
He can do whatever he wants.
And he added his own take to
my food, and it was great.
I was like, wow.
I was like, now I need
to go change the book
and include what he did.
That happened to me in Seattle.
But cooking's collaborative,
and is changing.
So tonight they
sent me the menu,
and the chef wrote
to me in French.
When French people
write letters,
is anyone in here French?
There's a real, it's very hard.
Did you ever have to
write a letter in French?
AUDIENCE: Very, very formal.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Yeah.
There's all these salutations,
and you end it with,
it doesn't really translate.
But it's like, I end this with
my distinguished salutations.
You're writing to
your cable company,
like why is my bill so high?
And you're like, I wish of you,
"Je vous en prie," yeah, yeah.
So he's writing me these
things, and we just email.
It's just [BLOWS RASPBERRY]
whatever you want to do.
So he's doing a much more
formal interpretation.
And a friend of mine who
writes about vegetarian cooking
did a dinner there
the other night.
She's like, I didn't
recognize the food,
because it was his
own interpretation.
Which is great, that's great.
I love it.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Awesome.
Well the next time, you and I
can go to Delfina or something
again.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: I
have an in, I just
found out I have an
in at the hottest
restaurant in San Francisco.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Which one?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: I can't
tell you on camera.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Oh, OK.
Well, we'll do it
when the camera--
DAVID LEBOVITZ: I have the
chef's cell phone number.
The power of the internet.
I was like, does anyone know--
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: How fancy.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: I'm
not going to go.
I actually, I'm a firm
believer in democracy.
So I think I should have
the chance everyone else--
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: I
have to call bullshit
on that, because I remember
last couple times ago,
you called us.
And you're like, can
you get us into Delfina?
And I think our
response was just that.
If anybody can get
into Delfina, you can.
And I don't know,
I think we ended up
getting the reservation.
But to hell with democracy
on that one, right?
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Well
I'm traumatized.
Because years ago,
a friend of mine
opened a restaurant
in San Fransisco.
It became really hot.
She goes well, if you
ever want to get in,
just tell them you're
a friend of mine.
So I called up.
I'm like hi, I'd like a
reservation for Thurs-- they're
like, we're all booked.
I'm like well, I'm a
friend of so and so.
The woman said, oh sure you are.
After that, I was like oh god.
I'm never doing that again.
JONATHAN ALFERNESS: Well, with
that David, thank you so much
for coming by to Google, we
really appreciate having you.
DAVID LEBOVITZ: Thank you.